the 1990s were a golden age of
television animation but cartoons are a
business and even the most beloved shows
were sometimes canceled to make room for
more profitable programming here are the
real reasons behind a few of those
controversial cartoon cancellations
after debuting on MTV in 1993 millions
of kids and adults watched the two
giggling moronic metalheads of beavis
and butt-head determine which bands were
cool and which sucked that is when they
weren't terrorizing their neighbors
teachers and burger world customers not
everybody liked Beavis and Butthead
politicians called out the show for
encouraging anti-social behavior and one
family blamed Beavis is pyromania for
leading to a deadly house fire nothing
stuck though and beavis and butt-head
remained the world's favourite idiots
however after 200 episodes and the
feature film beavis and butt-head do
America creator Mike judge decided it
was time to end it speaking to Los
Angeles Times judge said I actually
wanted to stop a little sooner after the
second season I thought how are we gonna
do this anymore
I was completely burned out judge wound
up sticking around for seven seasons but
in 1997 he moved on to other projects
like his Fox animated series king of the
hill starring three old-timey cartoon
characters named Yakko Wakko and dot
Warner who were more or less imprisoned
in the water tower on the Warner
Brothers movie lot Animaniacs was a
cartoon quickly embraced by both
children and adult audiences alike
debuting in 1993 Animaniacs satirized
cartoon tropes while being completely
self-aware offering up innuendo laced
dialogue and biting social commentary
among the kid-friendly laughs Animaniacs
ran for five seasons and spun off its
most popular side characters Pinky and
the brain before Kids WB ended the show
in 1998 according to creator Tom Ruger
the end came due to a business decision
regarding another much cheaper kid show
a Japanese anime series with massive
commercial potential
Ruger explained Kids WB was handed
Pokemon for free and it pulled down big
numbers so then they wanted everything
for free
Animaniacs cost warner brothers too much
money to make and promote so off it went
at first glance Todd McFarlane's
animated spawn series looked like a show
for kids but spawn was based off of
McFarland's top-selling comic series
extremely dark and violent story about a
former assassin who gets killed by his
boss sent to hell and ends up working
for Satan hardly family-friendly
material you me to deal with now boo job
spawn ran for three seasons on HBO and
won an Emmy Award for outstanding
animated program the show's third season
was a bust however and HBO's animation
division was withering on the vine after
enduring numerous production
difficulties the show earned a quiet
cancellation in 1999 Batman the Animated
Series represented a breakthrough in
television animation and comic book
adaptation moody quiet and literally
dark it demonstrated that there was a
market for dramatic superhero content
that could appeal to children and adults
this Batman was so highly regarded that
Fox aired the show in primetime for a
while and in 1993 the studio released
Batman mask of the phantasm in theaters
voice actor Kevin Conroy even tops many
lists of the best Batman actors however
in 1995 after three years and 85
episodes the series left the air
according to Conroy even though the
audience was still invested and the
actors were willing to continue the
creator's had run out of ideas and
wanted to end the show on a high note
they didn't want to compromise on the
quality of what they'd had and start
creating kind of silly stories
fortunately for Batman fans the story
ideas didn't dry up for long a sequel
series to the beloved show debuted a
couple of years after its cancellation
bringing back most of the animated
series cast and crew including Conroy
the new Batman adventures debuted on
Kids WB in September of 1997 originally
created for ABC The Critic was an
animated sitcom about a snobby hapless
New York City movie reviewer named Jay
Sherman he hates most movies he sees
tries to raise his son as best as he can
and fend off his wacky family according
to Jon Lovitz who provided the voice of
Jay we did it for ABC and ABC goes we
love it and then they cancelled it after
seven shows following it's ABC
cancellation The Critic moved over to
Fox and aired immediately after The
Simpsons where creators Al Jean and Mike
Reiss had previously worked as writers
and show
according to Lovitz The Critic brought
in excellent ratings for Fox retaining
90% of the huge Simpsons audience and
yet in 1994 Fox pulled the plug despite
a solid performance an executive at the
network thought the 8:30 p.m. Sunday
timeslot could be better used by a new
show gene explained the guy who ran the
network then John metoya
just didn't like the show he preferred
to show that no one remembers called
House of buggin with John Leguizamo the
sketch comedy debuted in early 1995 in
the place of the critic and lasted a
mere 10 episodes in the fall of 1994 the
syndicated Disney Afternoon programming
block mixed things up by adding
gargoyles to its lineup of silly
cartoons and wacky adventures this
contemplative and sometimes violent show
is stylistically different from its
Disney Afternoon predecessors like goof
troop tales Minh and ducktales similar
in tone and approach to batman the
animated series gargoyles concerns the
day-to-day activities of magical beings
who protect New York City at night
the characters were architectural
gargoyles by day imbued with the spirits
of 1000 year old Scottish folk creatures
gargoyles ran for three years and 78
episodes but was ultimately cancelled
because it wasn't a mega hit according
to the creator Greg Weisman it didn't
perform up to expectations Disney really
wanted it to outdo Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers and it failed to succeed at that
angry beavers tells the story of two
beaver bachelors named AG and Norb who
live in an Oregon forest by 2001 four
seasons had aired and cancellation
seemed imminent according to co-creator
Keith Catterick we were significantly
over-budget behind schedule and had
generally worn out our welcome realizing
that the end was near Kocurek and the
rest of the angry beavers staff decided
to go out on a blaze of glory Kocurek
and show staff writer Roger ash Bakker
wrote a script for a series finale
episode called bye-bye beavers an
installment equal parts dark and meta
Dagon nor become to realize that they
are not real but cartoons and that their
show is about to be canceled which means
they will cease to exist
at first Nickelodeon signed off on the
script but when executives noticed all
the jokes making fun of Nickelodeon they
reversed course according to writer
Michael Wright they saw it all put
together and said wait this makes us
look bad so they killed it the script
was never animated but
courting of the show's voice actors
reading it was made which leaked online
in 2006 by 1995 Comedy Central was
experimenting with original programming
and one of its first new shows was a
low-budget animated series with largely
improvised dialogue called dr. Katz
professional therapist doc does it
bother you when I touch your face like
this a little bit is that inappropriate
you know probably for me to hold my hand
there nope it's not a problem
comedian Jonathan Katz voiced a
therapist whose clients were all
stand-up comedians who'd lay on his
couch and relayed neuroses that were
really just bits from their stage
routines he also had a lazy adult son
named Ben and attempted to have a social
life ironically it's dr. Katz own
success that led to its demise the show
helped put Comedy Central on the TV map
showing that the channel had a unique
sensibility and was a home for animated
TV two years after its debut South Park
premiered on Comedy Central and became a
monster hit particularly with young male
viewers dr. Katz attracted an older
audience and since it wasn't in the
demographic that the now South Park
obsessed network was trying to lure it
got cancelled with the arrival of
child-friendly cable networks like
Nickelodeon and the popularity of
syndicated shows the ratings for once
beloved Saturday morning cartoons
started to slip NBC president Brandon
Tartikoff
analyzed the budgets and found that the
average Saturday morning cartoon cost
300 thousand dollars to produce
Tartikoff and his team realized that it
would be much cheaper to get rid of the
cartoons in favor of new shows or sports
in 1991 NBC signed a long-term contract
with Notre Dame to air the college's
games on Saturday mornings it cost the
network about 1 million dollars a game
which was still cheaper than programming
six hours of cartoons every week plus it
could charge higher advertising rates
for football than it could for kids
stuff in 1992 NBC switched to a lineup
that included The Today Show
football games and a block of low-budget
sitcoms like Saved by the Bell
eliminating the entire 1991 to 1992
Saturday morning cartoon schedule check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]